elle est douce et timide elle va nous
avons nous interpréter maman de la
chanteuse l'ouham donc à tonnerre
d'applaudissements période comme merial
ils sont plus d'une trentaine à avoir
tenté leur chance ils ont entre 11 et 25
ans et participe au concours des jeunes
talents de voisins-le-bretonneux je fais
de la musique depuis longtemps depuis
toujours mais j'avais envie de faire un
petit concert comme ça profitant de
l'été puis en plus il y avait un
concours de talent donc si je veux sinon
à s'amuser tout en étant un des portes
unités donc c'est une expérience aussi
ça me permet de faire des sciences de la
siagne voir comment ça se déroule à deux
surtout après six mois de répétitions
ces candidats sont évalués par un jury
d'experts
jules de radio sensations andy de déclic
théâtre ou encore un membre du conseil
municipal des jeunes suivent une grille
d'évaluation de la grande partie
techniques artistiques et après il ya le
volume souligne le bonus henning le
bonus wings et si on a bien ressenti ou
pas si on a aimé c'est le petit plus
c'est nous a fait chaud au coeur ou si
nous importe roady après il y aura
technique et artistique
voilà c'est l'emplacement de la scène
comment la personne arrive à s'en sortir
le concours est né de la collaboration
de plusieurs partenaires notamment le
service jeunesse de la commune et le
centre alfred de vigny
c'est de mettre en avant les jeunes donc
de 11 à à 25 ans delémont et roeser un
espace scénique de les faire monter sur
scène avec des talents que ce soit dans
le domaine du chant dans le domaine
musical
il ya aussi de la magie
y'avait aussi éventuellement des arts du
cirque pour cette première édition c'est
aymeric 12 ans imitateur de michael
jackson qui l'emportent pas de palme
pour les autres mais ils ont déjà
conquis le public